welcome to the across the spoiler verse
podcast ever since I've had that cold
I've stopped shouting the intros and I
wanted to be mysterious and gripping and
this week I thought it was going to be a
slow news we Greg but there's actually
quite a lot of things to talk about in
regards to Marvel and the news we're GNA
get into it I'm very I'm very excited
how are you doing I'm doing good po I'm
really I'm exhausted today I'm a little
under the weather too so I'm ready to be
the audience Cipher and just hear
everything for the first time from you
and then react in real time as most of
this as per usual that's my job here on
the podcast man it's for me to go what's
happening oh my God and then I give like
two lines to make it seem like I'm
contributing to this thing but I'm ready
man we I see this whole outline you you
[__] you message me this morning
being like yeah we don't really have
anything and then he sends me this
outline I'm like we got so many things
to talk about what is he talking about
this guy's crazy you got box office on
the first order of business business
here for this big box office news then
the SAG strike and then we've got some
James Bond news some Spider-Man 2 first
thought and or a little review of it
then some Spider-Man 4 updates Loki
season 2 episode 4 review yes we've seen
it early the news about the Deadpool
delays Marvel's tracking and also a book
I've been listening to over the weekend
uh MCU the ROM Marvel Studios absolutely
fantastic Greg it's provided a whole
different insight to the MC you that i'
never even thought of before I'm going
to be talking about that in general you
know what I've I don't want to spoil the
whole book I know we're heavy spoilers
here but there's so many interesting
things and yeah just stuff I want to
talk about because I absolutely love
listening to it no man now we have a we
have a topic there you know one of those
I read the MCU the reign of Marvel
Studios so you don't have to type of
deals man that should be the name of
this episode yeah but definitely go
check it out I mean I got it for $9.99
on Apple audio books and worth it worth
every penny it's about 16 hours long
when I've been going for my walks and
stuff I've been sucking the podcasts off
listening to that and yeah just all the
ups and downs of Marvel and stuff
they're talking about for the future as
well it's absolutely fantastic but we've
got some bad news to start off with Greg
well some positive news maybe um but the
killers of the flower Moon that's taken
second place behind the era's tour at
the domestic box office and it's brought
in $23 million
with a global total of $44 million now I
know you've seen this it's rare I've
seen both movies in the top box office
I've seen them both yeah so what were
your thoughts on flower killer moons uh
well I've mentioned this before scorsi
is my all-time favorite director uh I
was looking through his filmography I'm
pretty sure there's only like maybe one
of his movies I haven't seen one maybe
one or two um but so yeah I'm I'm a huge
score Cy fan and I've seen most of them
multiple times and so I was really
looking forward to this film and I I I I
honestly I'm not sure I even saw the
trailer for the movie and I'm seing like
Snippets here or there so I was really
looking forward to it and uh I agree
with every sentiment I've heard about
everything from a technical scale like
my G to give like the really short
version review of a three and a half
hour film uh like I think the
performances are phenomenal uh Lily
Gladstone is incredible if she does not
get an Oscar nomination that is a crime
a like a serious serious crime DiCaprio
is doing his third Southern idiot I love
watching him he's like the biggest idiot
in the world I think it's probably the
dumbest protagonist I've ever seen and
it's like he's intentionally dumb
dumbest protagonist that uh SC says he's
ever had and dairo is in top form one of
his best performances in the most recent
years maybe one of his best performances
of all time uh shot great as expected
production design value and it's it is a
very important story I did find myself
afterwards looking up more about it
because I I wasn't aware of this story
because I am a naive American and I
wanted to learn a little bit more and I
thought the story itself of what they
talked about was
impactful uh that being said you know it
is a three and a half hour movie and I'm
not bothered by runtime that wasn't
something that was actually turning me I
mean part of me was like it was a long
time to be in the theater but I I've
seen a bunch of long movies and so I
that wasn't really a problem I did think
though that overall I was never fully
immersed into the movie I still found
myself kind of at a distance with the
experience like I I I was constantly
interested in what was happening but I
still registered more as like an
observation piece to me more than an
emotional piece while there's you know
some serious harrowing stuff that goes
down in this movie while there's some
really impactful things that that do
happen
contextually I still found myself more
in an in an observation audience seat
member rather than being on someone's
emotional journey and and one of the
first things I said was I I wish it was
a little bit more from the uh a people's
perspective more Lily Gladstone's
perspective and then I went online
that's been a big thing that people have
been talking about all over social media
common thing too yeah it is it is a and
I found myself craving that when I was
when I was watching the movie um I saw
the language translator actually said
that at the premiere or the guy who they
brought on screen
consult about everything I saw he was
talking about it and it's kind of like
whoa that's pretty wild to be saying
that at the premiere but I mean if he's
saying it then I guess it's definitely a
valid point you know what I mean there's
no there's definitely no bias there but
to his point you know like he he was
saying that yeah you need it to be from
if you're going to do it from the a
people it should probably be done by an
a director uh you know someone with that
lineage of some sort right um what it
did do though was I I think it
effectively got done what someone like
myself who doesn't really know about
this stuff it they wanted to communicate
what the story was about they wanted to
get people interested in it and I think
to that effect with a movie where its
message and context is so
important that's what I think was you
could feel that fervor behind the camera
behind the writing all of it you know
and it it did have that impact of uh I
am I am finding myself actually
researching the story now and wanting to
understand it better because it did open
my eyes to it and overall I still like I
I still like the film I still like the
film quite a bit actually I just wasn't
in I wasn't in love with it to the
degree that maybe a scorsi fan like
myself would hope to and I like a lot of
the scorsi films that are not like his
gangster films like I really love
silence um I I I know gangs yor is still
like a gangster movie but that is more
like historical period piece uh type of
deal that he's done you know so yeah uh
overall still I think there's a lot of
great Merit to it regardless and I did
not expect it to do well it's not Nolan
a three three-hour Nolan film is very
different than a three-hour scorsi film
three- hour Nolan film still wants to
entertain you and go for spectacle while
killers of the flower Moon has a bit of
that old school Ken Burns effect where
it's it it does feel like you're just
kind of PL in time like people have been
calling it epic I wouldn't even call it
an epic like it's it's long and it's a
period piece but it's epic and runtime
and as a but but it's yeah it's not like
a spectacle type of film
whatsoever yeah I mean every time I've
seen anyone talk about it the Run time's
been something that everyone's brought
up um and I think it has kind of
overshadowed it and to be honest it it
did put me off going to see it and it's
not because I don't like long movies I
mean just I I worked out you know it's a
three and a half hour movie trailers are
30 minutes long it's four hours and then
I've got to travel there and travel back
and I just I don't have that personal
capacity just with my family and stuff I
don't actually have that time if I was a
a young man again you know back in my
20s before I had kids and stuff I would
have definitely went out and seen it but
just everything kind of with that I just
couldn't balance it with my own personal
life um and it is a shame but it it has
kind of all Grace Randol I was watching
her box office podcast and it has kind
of brought up the fact that you know
every every time we talk about people up
there with Christopher Nolan will say
like James Cameron Martin scorey and so
on but I think it has kind of shown that
maybe Martin scorey doesn't have the
pull that Nolan does which is reflected
in the box office now an interesting
thing as well is that it's getting it
it's been put out in cinemas but it was
or it is pretty much going to be aimed
at a streaming release and Apple in
Paramount produced it I believe and it's
going to be dropped on streaming
relatively shortly so maybe people were
just holding off for that as well I
don't know how well known that is but I
feel like they dropped it now in
theaters so it could be an Oscar
Contender and build up some buzz and
then you know when they release it
properly on streaming which was the the
reason that they got him on board it was
the same with the Irish man and that can
kind of be used to to make people sign
up to Apple because let's be honest it
doesn't have that massive subscriber
base that you know your Disney plus and
your Netflix and Max does so yeah we'll
see how it does um it might end up
pulling in more money I'll be surprised
if more streaming services keep offering
Martin scorei $250 million budget movies
to to launch their streaming services or
get subscribers in but yeah I've heard
good things about it I've just heard a
lot of the criticisms of you know the
the pacing and the run time which you it
is difficult to keep people engaged for
three and a half hours let's be honest
I'm sure
it requires patience man it is it is a
meditative deliberate cold experience
requires patience um and it is kind of
funny that these streaming services they
do sort of just throw money at scores
because they want the clout they want
that that name ass that Prestige name
Association uh with him and for the kind
of movies that like where whereas like
James Cameron and Nolan they create
movies that can actually generate box
office revenue you know whereas like
scor says he wants to do these very long
expensive films uh which fit more in in
this current climate I was going to
upset people because I always I saw
Irishman in the theaters I saw this in
the theaters I didn't wait for streaming
um but with the way audiences have been
trained I totally get that his movies
for the kind of like specifically these
kind of why people would wait for
streaming I don't it's not my preferred
method it's not I'm not saying it's the
way to do it I'm saying it makes sense
to I mean everything in general is just
more expensive as well Netflix announced
they're doing another price hike and I'm
already paying £21 a month for that and
just thinking like I it genu I know it's
part of my job but it this is the first
price hike where it's genuinely cross my
mind should I cancel Netflix and you
know to get movie tickets on top of that
just everything's so expensive um people
are being very very selective with what
they're spending their money on and if
they're even mildy excited about
something might not go see it now
speaking of mildy excited about things
The Hunger Games The Ballad of the song
birds and snakes apparently that's
tracking to earn 35 to 45 million during
that opening weekend at the domestic box
office which would make it the lowest in
the franchise now because Rachel zler is
in it you already know what the
narrative is gonna be you know what the
narrative is gonna be but I think it go
I mean you know that a negative Aura is
going to be spun on YouTube about her
being part of the film I personally
think it it's not all her fault because
there's like Rachel zler is not in every
movie at the moment and there's lots of
movies bombing right now so I don't
think people can blame it fully on here
um and I think in general people are
just exhausted with kind of seeing the
same old thing there's a lack of
promotion as well um obviously the
actors are still on strike and there's
there's nothing in that marketing that
makes me desperate to see it you know
what I mean it's like when we were
talking about the Marvel's and which
we'll get on to in in a bit but there's
not that money shot in the trailer or
that that thing that's really selling it
and I think in general prequels kind of
have a difficult problem getting people
on board because there's very few really
good prequel films and a lot of the time
it's just things you've seen before
repackaged make it look slightly older
you know they'll get they'll get the
style of the original movies scale back
the technology a bit and then launch it
like that so
yeah there was nothing in that that I
felt like I I have I need to go and see
this you know what I mean it's kind of
not really sold it to me and then but
obviously it's all it's all Rachel C's
fault it's all her fault because she did
that Snow White interview and for
variety on the red carpet so what are
your thoughts on that Greg speaking of
snow when I saw the trailer it's seems
that the main character is actually the
young Donald
is is am I correct about that is and I I
and he's like the villain in the in the
original
films and so they're going to make him
like the protagonist if I'm correct
right like that's who he's this guy is
playing Anakin Skywalker in it they're
making Anin Skywalker the the main
character I feel like the
trailers are not really
communicating the tragedy
behind the the impending tragedy of
what's to come with this character or
watch how he morphed from oh he's a guy
we actually like in rudor he seems like
a good dude like I think there's like
shades of that but I think we need to
sell them on it because I think
naturally with a prequel a lot of times
we feel like we know what the outcome
ultimately might be and and so you
really got to get them strongly invested
in a character you know like I I think
one of the best prequels is uh X-Men
first Class and yeah like we we know
those characters Magneto and Professor X
so we we wanted to actually see like how
the relate because they only like
alluded to it and but but what that
trailers what the trailer sold you on
was not
really what the what those trailers are
what I remember them selling us on is
how their relationship started off good
and then we were going to see what led
to them their divide and that was a
compelling selling point and and here it
is just the first Hunger Games you know
and Hey look it's that guy who is not
Jennifer Laur it's like the not the main
people you didn't really show up to this
Hunger Games movies for and and now
here's a younger version of them that
being said though I I do like the
trailers um not to just be like all
negative about it like I get why it's
not being as appealing as it ought to be
uh however I I see the trailers and I do
think like I like the mood of it I like
the tone and and I I tend to buy into
the seriousness of it and that guy from
stranger things whose name I'm totally
blanking on that one kid the funny one
he's in it too and I'm like I'm excited
to see him do like a different kind of
portrayal than what I'm used to because
the only thing I've seen him in is
stranger things there's a lot that I'm
actually looking forward to am I clamp
into go see this not really however I
don't feel like I'd be like remissed to
you know I would still like to go see it
though I I am I am interested in it
President Snow he's not Darth Vader and
he's not Bess XA Magneto so there's not
that need to really learn about his
backstory like everything I need to know
it's in it's in those original films um
whereas Darth Vader obviously when you
learn his Luke's father and stuff you
kind of want to see his relationship
with Obi-Wan and the Jedi Order and
stuff so they have way more things that
they can sell that movie on so yeah kind
of makes sense why it's not as
successful as it was but the studio have
cleverly they've not announced there's
an entire shared Cinematic Universe
being built around it they've just said
look we're doing this one and if it does
well we'll do more they haven't been
like oh we're making a new Hunger Games
trilogy so yeah the there it seems like
it's it probably you know underperformed
but to be fair a lot of films this year
been underperforming and I'm sure Rachel
zler is going to shoulder all the blame
for it she had to do with everyone one
of them it's reason the flash tank she
makes good clicks on YouTube and they
can keep using that thumbnail where she
says weird weird um so yeah get it on
get it make every video on YouTube about
that now they're going to have to
because there's not much happening in
terms of acting at the moment um the SAG
after strike has kind of stalled at the
moment though talks are resuming as we
release this um but yeah there was a big
big crazy weekend where they basically
released a statement and told actors not
to dress up as popular characters from
struck content for Halloween or post the
images on social media so it's like well
if I'm not dressing up I'm not going to
be posting them on social media but um
former sag president Melissa Gilbert she
came out and said that it was basically
stupid and said do you really think this
kind of infantile stuff is going to end
the strike we look like a joke please
tell me going to make this rule go away
and go negotiate this is the kind of
silly [__] that keeps us on strike
completely agree 100% And yeah when this
thing got announced I even screenshot
you the tweet and sent it like look at
this [__] sake what what are they
doing I think Ryan reynolds's uh tweet
that was the first thing I saw I didn't
even know what it was uh that tweet was
so funny of I'm gonna what was it about
did you see that tweet that he said
about like I'm going to yell at my
daughter call her a scab or something
like that yeah so that's so [__]
funny but that even like Ryan around was
Al that that is a indic like he's a huge
actor he one his aist and that that the
tone of that tweet I'm not a lot of
times you gota look at tones and just
take jokes for what they are however
with it being the sax freg you could
tell there's the implication that like
even he's going this is a little this is
a little much this a little far-fetched
what they're asking for right now yeah
just completely pointless um doesn't
help them in any way I would say we I
mean we've been prettyy Pros Pro Union
the entire time um but yeah seeing stuff
like this it's like have you heard of
stop oil Greg they're basically a
protest group but they go around
destroying stuff and do that as their
protest and I'm I'm all for it mate I'm
all I believe in pollution I believe in
climate change but just as the way they
go about it I think it put I think it
turns more people against them then gets
them on their side and I think actions
like this do the same thing so yeah not
a not a good move but apparently they're
going to be reversing that or they've
they've put something out to that effect
I think some people really quick just to
interject sometimes you like to
criticize a an element of something here
with the with the sag's
approach that does not mean we are not
actually in favor of the bigger picture
of what they are fighting for I I think
a lot of times that just gets so
misconstrued like it has to be all
nothing or black or white thinking I'm
like no it it definitely doesn't have to
be we're not it's not a religion like we
can we can be we could be critical of
some stuff of certain approaches and
tactics uh and and then go but the
actual things you're fighting for and
what you want like yeah I support that
and I and I am on board for what you're
fighting for in the amptp ultimately is
still the enemy here well if the former
sag president's saying it I think I
think that's fair think that's fair
enough I think if they're saying it then
they probably got a point um but they've
basically C so film updates on Twitter
that they've basically calculated all of
the the costs that the strikes have
caused and apparently it's resulted in
A5 billion loss to California's economy
the loss of 45,000 jobs and a 400
million hit to the full box office which
is crazy because the the Stu I mean
we've been saying this for so long what
like why are the studios being so
difficult and and dragging the heel and
stuff and obviously you know the actors
have fired back on stuff as well but to
hear the the full cost of it insane yeah
it's absolutely I mean I'm out here I
see it you know I'm in the heart of
where the SAG strike is the SAG strike
is happening like um I think like a 10
minute like where the main pickets are
or like a 10 to 15 minute drive away
from where I'm at and you do see how it
affects like restaurants too and coffee
shops and all these other people as well
it's really it's really s it's really
disheartening and you know I I know
quite a few people who are in Sag as
well I even go to the gym and I'm seeing
the Gym's less busy now too so that's
like my one little bias personal benefit
is I don't have to wait as long to do
legs wait for that squat rack for a half
hour like I normally do because not
enough people can go to sh sad sad maybe
I maybe I should J about it maybe I
should I'll cut all out should
I no so um yeah speaking of actors can
we keep in US discussing if we should
cut it can we keep all that
in yeah I'm just you're getting
cancelled and everyone's going to not
listen to the show anymore so brilliant
well done Greg your joke has cost us as
well I notic if I joke about stuff like
that here I get in trouble if I joke
about that stuff on real rejects people
are like people it doesn't matter so I
think we should just take the
risk okay we'll do it then but it's your
funeral now speaking of funeral
the last James Bond had a funeral in it
it was the funeral of James Bond but
like all things the life goes on and
they've decided that they're bringing
back James Bond however Barbara Brockley
she's come out I can't believe I'm still
riding this segue Barbara Brockley come
out and said the James Bond TV spin-offs
will not happen they're not making any
James Bond TV spin-offs our focus is on
making feature films when we get going
on a Bond movie It Takes our full
attention for three to four years so
that's our focus and that comes from an
interview in the guardian and I
completely agree with her 100% I'm so
happy I think it's the right thing to do
I think that making cheap TV adaptations
that don't quite live up to the films
it's going to dilute the brand and
completely kill the box office of the
next film I think yeah it's right I mean
I I did talk about this on Twitter
earlier um I
read the the response from someone um
because I thought it was quite an
interesting point but they basically
said that I'm not going to name and
shame them Greg I don't want people
going after them to kill them and stuff
because I know what my followers are
like and I'll be lucky if you're still
here next week after after those jokes
but they said um their focus on feature
films meanwhile it's been two years
since no time to die and apparently
they're not even really ready for Bond
26 and I said yeah I said well to be
fair they killed the character off and
they're going with a new actor and style
and I feel like they just want to get
give it some room and get it right you
know the next 10 it's like Superman
Legacy for me where this next thing like
how good this next James Bond film
that's going to carry the next 10 years
of James Bond they have to really nail
down everything about it whenever you
bring in a new James Bond actor you have
to realize that he's probably going to
be in it for the long hole if they flop
on that first film it's going to affect
so many different things going forward
and it's going to be an uphill battle to
get people invested in that I mean
George Len be is the perfect example
they had Shan conry re he left they
brought George L be in I think he I I
think looking back he was good but he
clearly wasn't accepted by the the
general public at the time and they had
to basically recast with Roger Mo the
film after and they don't want to be in
a situation like that where that just
having to constantly it could I mean it
could kill a brand and and doing TV
shows like this we've seen with we've
seen how Disney have been dead set on
doing TV shows and how much it's diluted
the box offices of their their big big
tent poles like Star Wars and
Marvel well you skipped out on T doll by
the
way Timothy Dalton who a lot of people
find
he yeah yeah he was lot
people people thought he was actually
like he was
underrated what happened with him was PS
Broan was going to be in the role but
they had a contract close on Remington
steel where they could extend it and
then when there were talks and there
were rumors that Pi broen was going to
be Bond Remington steel guys that
thought let's extend it um and then they
brought Dalton in to do it but I think
Dalton's good they went with a c he was
kind of the Prototype Daniel Craig where
they went with a much more serious tone
because Roger Mo love the guy love him
love his eyebrow acting
can that was great but he took it in a
very goofy Direction by the end of it
and they wanted to make it more serious
so D came on board and Licensed to Kill
I think was the first
15 in in case you don't know Greg
because you're American in the UK we
don't have R ratings and stuff we have U
for Universal PG for Parental Guidance
12 you can watch it if you're 12 15 and
then 18 is like our top level um and he
he was a 15 you see what I'm saying it's
gritty yeah you've got to be 15 to watch
this mate you can't be 14 and watching
James Bond so it's like this is edgy it
was not quite the Logan but almost the
Logan yeah man I agree this is uh I I
didn't know there were TV spinoffs even
like as a consideration I didn't even
know that well Amazon bought the rights
to him so you might actually see a
trailer knocking about for a game show
that they're doing with Brian Cox right
called something like
007 one to one million or something it's
basically a game show but they've got I
don't know why Brian Cox is involved
because he's never been in a a James
Bond film before but um it's called 007
road to a million it's on Amazon Prime
video uh it's it's basically a game show
where he's like James Bond stunts you
got to do the tricks and stuff um and I
when I saw that I was thinking right
Amazon have bought the rights we're
gonna get 20 different TV shows on Prime
video a week
um but the broccoli have come out and
said look mate not doing it we're going
to have Bond show up shag some birds
jump off a cliff with a parachute some
theme tune's GNA play and then they're
gonna he's going to go on a mission to
stop some people in shags and birds on
the way and that's basically the plot of
every James Bond film
so takes him five years to write that
Greg it but at the same time though I
mean I get I get it yeah at the same
time I I I love the statement
because you know bond has been able to
last for so long where you know
sometimes they get flops and then other
times they get like massive hits you
know if I'm not mistaken Skyfall was the
first one to crack a billion dollars and
that was like late into the game of
James Bond you know and because they
know how to take breaks with Bond they
know how to space out Bond they don't
they don't just keep you never I I don't
ever hear the conversation about and
maybe I just missed out on it I don't
ever hear the conversation about Bon
fatigue you know like it is just one of
those
franchises that seems to just be
Everlasting because they know how to
space it out and I think what they did
with Daniel Craig is very very
interesting they essentially wrote
themselves into a weird corner and that
a lot of times that can sound like a bad
thing but sometimes the greatest
projects come out of doing your best to
be get really inventive and really
creative to write yourself out of a
corner not take a cheap route out like
oh Daniel Craig is actually alive and
now we've just you know did a new
casting for Bond because that's not the
case of what you can do they did they
took a different approach with bond from
Casino Royale to no time to die and they
ended up doing something nevero which
they killed the guy off it's very very
fascinating stuff what they did and so
this would be the first time where
because you know people were like Casino
Royale is a origin story uh and and it
was but it was also like it wasn't going
to the time period of sha connory so it
wasn't like you were doing the origin
story leading that would lead into sha
connory you know it was tied in it was
tied in but it was still modern day so
it's very it's a very different approach
and then and they so they they a lotted
themselves an opportunity to do some
type of Otherworldly or or genre Bend
with it where it's not like it's the
same Bond we've been watching this
entire time and the fact that they
killed them off is this would be the
first time where it's like we get a new
Bond every so many years or whatever
every so many movies we we we get a we
get a new Bond and and I think this
would be the first time where it truly
feels like this is
definitively a brand new James Bond
right now because they died and now we
are starting over you know and it's
going to be very very different and I I
hope they're able to pull it off I'm
really I'm really curious and I'm so
glad they're not rushing it because it's
given us time to let it go you know and
I and I think I think other franchises
can learn thing or two about what has
allowed James Bond to be so prevailing
for so many years and why there's you
don't hear this conversation about let
Bond die you know because people like
seeing it and they they've kept it
simple they have kept it simple the GRE
ones went a little bit more complex with
the character I say a lot more complex
with the character than you normally do
and now it's now it's like what line do
you ride do you go more into depth with
who is James Bond and why is Bond the
way he is or do you go back to more
basics of something more superficial
like what you were talking about you
know uh I don't I don't know what you do
but I think they can do something very
intriguing yeah no I agree I'm very
excited for it I know there's lots of
talks at the moment that they should go
back to the 60s and do it as a period
piece I personally disagree I always
feel like James Bond should very much be
a product of his time and I think that
every generation should have their own
bond that kind of fits in and so far
we've had that you know Conor's the 60s
Mo's the 70s Dalton's the 80s sort of
but Mo did a lot of the 80s as well
broen's the 90s and then Craigs the
naughties and I feel like you know you
can see certain things in all of those
films that kind of feel like time
capsules almost and I think going to a
period piece you're going to lose out on
the gadget certain things going on in
the world I would like to just see a
James Bond for this new generation
coming up and I think stalling things
out giving it a bit of time you know
you're gonna get that and I I'm really
excited to see what happens I I
absolutely love James Bond I think the
Craig stuff was kind of almost like a
like a Marvel Ultimate Comics run of him
if that makes sense
comics in case you guys don't know it
was like the the best stories of the
heroes condensed into a certain time
period and they went back like for
example with Spider-Man they told his
origin story and then his first battle
with the Green Goblin you know Gwen
Stacy's death how he got the symbiot
suit and I mean it's to it's told over
like maybe 200 issues or something I
think and I feel like that is what
Craig's Bond was even the way no time to
die ends which is his wife and well not
his wife but his girlfriend and his
daughter kind of driving along in an
ason Martin and she's telling the story
of James Bond I feel like it's very much
someone telling the best James Bond
stories which is why blofeld and stuff
pops up from time to time completely out
of Border timeline wise um but yeah
excited to see what happens with it and
that doesn't take us out all into our
next story which is uh Spider-Man 2 the
first thoughts and review so uh yeah
haven't really been ping it much have
you Greg you've been watching cutscenes
I've been doing the cut scenes a little
bit again like uh I I have I have
actually have the game um but um I
wouldn't be able to really sit down
proper and play it until and I know some
people on my like on the audience side
of real reject like why are you doing
this I'm like well I said I I I I gave
you guys a heads out this what I'm going
to be doing because I needed the I
wanted to do coverage for it and I
probably wouldn't be able to get around
to sit down and play it properly
honestly yes look like after
Thanksgiving just looking at this
current schedule maybe like like actual
Christmas time and you know I've done
that thing where I like rush to review a
game and rush through it and it's by
rushing I mean like 40 hours and then
trying to get a review up and stuff and
it's it's just like it it it robs me of
the of the enjoyment Factor you know so
I'm able to just take in the story right
now which is great because then I could
really take my time with seen still the
exact same story I mean experiencing it
surprised and getting all the story
beats the same I don't I'm I'm Ling the
story though I like I I don't find
myself go like I might have a moment or
two where I'm like oh I wish I saw the
gameplay but I love having that reserve
for me and I'm really I am loving the
story a lot I'm only about halfway
through he does have the black suit
right now at this point uh but I I think
it the more it goes the better it gets
and so far right now now like I don't
know what the ultimate end of the story
is going to be the one thing I wasn't
expecting to walk away from is this is
one of my favorite Harry Osborne's I've
I've ever seen like I I've seen in in
terms of like adaptation you know I I
I've watched um Spectacular Spider-Man I
really love that show and of course the
90s Spider-Man series the liveaction
ones and this is probably my favorite
Harry Osborne uh so far I know it's like
the thing everyone wants to talk about
you know like I love the black suit I
think the way it's visually realized is
great I love hearing Yuri lowenthal's
voice just snap into the the rage and
it's and and when the visuals go dark
there's like certain elements that kind
of gave me shades of last of us too uh
especially the first time he gets the
black suit is what I'll say uh there
there's a lot of great dark like when it
when it does go dark I really really
find it uh truly compelling stuff and it
just kind of just keeps getting better
and better uh I I am finding myself
currently like I'm only about I'm a
little more than halfway through the big
chunk of the cutscenes and maybe I
wouldn't feel this way if I was actually
doing the gameplay right currently
because I I did play the first two games
just so people know I actually sat down
and played those but the craving the
hunter is one character where I I am
craving a little bit more like I think
he's menacing and
threatening for the most part absolutely
I still I I do find myself kind of
craving a little bit more from just the
actual scenes from him some of his
dialogue just seems a little little
repetitive you know I'm looking for a
hunt and my
hunt most of his lines just come down to
I want my hunt you know and I I wish
there was a little bit more Nuance I
suppose to him is the one thing I'm kind
of missing I mean gameplay wise with him
you a lot of the time you're fighting
his Lackey who are also dressed in like
f jackets with swords and shields and
stuff um so yeah I can totally see what
you mean by that I think in general how
I feel about the game is that it it's a
step up from you know the first two I'm
counting miles and Morales as its game I
know some people think it's just an
expansion but it's I would say it's a
step up from that yeah much in the same
way that Arkham City is an Arkham night
kind of you can see the evolution there
and in terms of traversal I keep joking
that they should call him glider man
because I'm just gliding everywhere but
the once you start chaining things to
together and you can slingshot and glide
and swing and it just all works so well
and it feels like a complete Evolution
much in the same way that Arkham Knight
had the Batmobile and stuff and you
would dive into that drive along launch
yourself out it's so fluid um and the
city is so realized it just feels like
it's living and breathing and I know
there's lots of stupid comments on
Twitter right now being like you can't
go ride the Subway or you can't ride
your bike on to the subway line it's
like mate what what are you talking
about it just not you're not meant to be
able to do that like why why are you
buying this game to do that um and but I
just think it's such a well realized
world and not to sound cliche because
I'm sure every single review's done this
and they've also done the parody of it
as well but it makes you feel like
Spiderman and that's yeah definitely
what I wanted from it now I'm not going
to spoil it um but I do feel I was
trying to think before right is this the
best p and Miles story we've ever got
cuz I feel like right and I'm not I
can't recall in the comics completely
but I always feel like they've never
really had that full relationship with
each other where he's been a proper
mentor to Miles and and so on there's
always been something that's popped up
for example obviously miles was
introduced in the Ultimate Comics but
Peter died in that and then you have the
spiderverse films where you know Peter
dies at the start of it and then one
comes from another world but then he has
to go back home and then across the
spiderverse he comes in and it's there's
never really that solid Peter and Miles
thing whereas I feel with this it's like
a true Peter and Miles story where
there's not those existential things
like the Multiverse or them yeah being
set in another universe or they kill a
character off it's just them getting to
actually grow and and spend time
together and kind of see how the other
can help them out and obviously you know
Peter's set up as that that Mentor in
miles's life but with this you kind of
see how he needs miles as well because
of the stuff with the Venom story and
how the Symbiote attaches to him and I
don't believe I've ever seen it where
Peter's been struggling with the the
Venom symbiote but there's been miles
there as well to help him out and go
through it I think that's such an
interesting Dynamic story-wise to the
point where I think you're completely
right with the Craven stuff um I'm not
going to spoil what happens to him but
it it kind of felt like it could have
been any villain really um and they
didn't quite get into the depth that I
was really hoping that they would with
him he still works well but there's no
there's no connection to Peter really I
think what they've done brilliantly in
the series is even villains like Doc
Octopus who they've not they you know in
the comics they've not had that massive
connection to each other but then
they've done stuff like Dr Octopus is
mar and a May whereas in the first game
he was his mentor and stuff and it it
felt like Harry had a connection to him
and there's some villains that pop up in
this that have connections to Peter
whereas Craven he's just kind of popping
up in the city to basically do a
crocodile dunde and and just have a
blast but they give him a reason for why
he's doing it it's quite a pant thing
and yeah they handle him still pretty
well I think but I can totally see why
they were like I I believe they they
probably came in with the idea of
craving for this game and then realize
you know we we should really do the
symbiote suit in this because it's not
quite enough to carry a game but yeah
really enjoyed it um I think
everything's a step up from it it's
obviously getting R reviews except for
from IGN who I think gave an eight out
of 10 I feel it deserves it's either a
nine or a 10 um and yeah there's there's
so much in it that I love even just the
way it opens with sand man it just
completely pulls you into it and you can
when you're getting thrown across the
city by a giant sand man you you just
like this is this is the next step up
this is it this is like where things
should be going and the story works so
well the characters are really welld
developed it feels like a proper
Spider-Man story and it makes you feel
like Spider-Man I think there's they
amplify a lot more of the malevolence I
think there's more of this monstrosity
element to it a lot more of these like
horror creature Vibes even right from
the Sandman stuff you know like like
this is like like kind of almost a Kaiju
movie in a way just of how how vast the
scale is of it you know and and how much
destruction there's happening and and
how horrific it all is and I think too
to your point about like with Miles and
Peter what I've been loving so far is
like while Peter is the one who always
has to like honing on the good and he's
dealing with the grief of an May and you
know of course we know what happens when
symbiota attaches himself to Peter and
brings out the darkness within him and
such you have
dealing with his own Darkness as well
without a symbiote you know and how
that's been a prevailing part of his
character Journey with Martin Lee and
wanting to extract revenge and watching
how that will affect choices when so
much of about Spider-Man is about
responsibility is about choice I love
the line uh that the bar that Aunt May
drops uh or or like they explain that
that not ant May is alive or something
it they they expl something that ant May
said to him at one point in his life was
that balance is um a process not a
destination I'm like that is such a
poignant that such a powerful line to me
and it is the theme of it I love how
when Peter hears it though he's like oh
that's interesting I should have maybe M
had a point about like you mean you
haven't thought about this yet like this
is this is like your whole character you
should you should have been thinking
about this the entire time that's just
my favorite Little Nugget In Like A a
split second in the game of him going H
maybe she had a point to that and I'm
like yeah it's you're Spider-Man that is
your struggle right there struggle for
balance um yeah but yeah it's good good
stuff good stuff I don't know it's just
a lesson you can walk away with I think
in like real life is because people
always talk about balance you gotta find
balance and I and I do I I what I what I
think of why Spider-Man has connected
with so many people is those
relatability uh qualities and and and
the themes and the lessons that you can
actually take away from a Spider-Man
story despite of being like so fictional
and Larger than Life a quote like that
is is just a good lesson in life to
apply that it is a practice it is a
discipline it's not really a a thing you
just land on you know makes me feel like
I'm a bad parent because I don't spout
off any of the famous inspirational
quotes that both Uncle Ben and Aunt May
did you know what I mean that I ain't
got nothing like that I'm like put that
put that plug socket down don't eat it
you get in trouble and my my kids will
grow up like yeah always remember dad
used to say put that plug socket down
and he was right so yeah great game love
it um I hope you guys have played it or
even watch the cut scenes because it's
it's like a movie it's that level of
quality everyone's given a great
performance they're sort of becoming
almost the the characters to me the
people who do the voices much in the
same way that you know Kevin Conroy
became Batman and when I'm reading
Spider-Man stuff I'm starting to think
of our Yuri's voice in my head bit
creepy I know you interviewed him um
don't tell him I said that yeah but K
interviewed him so he didn't watch this
so he he won't know um but yeah we've
got more Spider-Man Updates this time
over to the movies so Sony according to
Daniel rpk they're developing a wraith
movie so Sony you know they love they
love the Spider-Man spin-off they've got
I've actually listened to a really
interesting chapter in the MC reign of
Marvel Studios book talking about how
Sony during far from home so so
basically what happened with Sony was
they they weren't getting what they
wanted with their Amazing
Spider-Man and and what happened was
Kevin was like you know Kevin fgy he was
like oh well we we'll take care of him
and apparently Amy Pascal threw a
sandwich off his face told him a [__]
off and they they weren't going to do it
it and um wait wait you're not like
you're not making some joke like that's
what they said happen this is in the
book no so so Kevin F yeah Kevin FY
invited Amy Pascal out to a hotel to
kind of talk about maybe bringing
Spider-Man into the MCU um and what she
did was just told him to as soon as he
suggested it apparently got threw a
sandwich off him told him [__] off and
then what happened was the the interview
do you remember the interview with um
the the Kim Jong IL or Kim Jong on um
parody yeah interview with James so
apparently what happened after that
was people this is according to the book
people inside the Korean government
hacked Sony and leaked all the emails
and then that's what made the the talks
happen again but so Kevin FY you know
they produced um homecoming first ever
film to to make a billion for um Sony I
believe it was I'll double check that
just to make sure um but I'm pretty sure
it was yeah so homecoming did the the
880 and I think it was far from home did
the billion and but during that Sony
were like oh well we don't actually need
mobile Studios so we're going to cut the
deal we get full ownership of the
character and then uh yeah they that's
that's when they've started doing their
spin-offs again and stuff which For
Better or Worse you know we we have to
cover them and I'll tell you what Greg
there were rumors that the Madame web
trailer was going to Rel today and I was
like I just can't be honest I've got far
too much in my plate got Invincible
coming up lowkey chvy Five Nights at
Freddy's the ring and I just thought I
hope it doesn't drop because I just
cannot be about that and but yeah so
that that's kind of going on a a
long-winded way to say that they're
developing a WRA movie we're going to
have to Pretend We're big wraith fans
for the next year or so um so yeah what
what your thought on that I think it's
going to get canceled man who who's
going to give a [__] about this rith is
one of those characters that I think you
could I I am not far enough along in the
game please don't tell me to know if Ray
I know that Yuri Watanabe is one of the
PE like becomes wraith Yuri Yuri was in
the first game as well yes so I'm I'm
not but I'm saying like in Spider-Man 2
I'm not far enough along to know if in
the game there's a hint that becomes
that or something you know what I mean
like so I don't know
um I think wraith is one of those
characters that if you brought them into
like if you brought like Yuri Watson Al
for example into live action you tease
them as that first and then they become
wraith down the road yeah yeah I don't
know if I don't know about a standalone
movie though you know like I I don't
know if that's something people are
going to be interested enough in it but
get there's a there's a scenario I
suppose where you could do it and then
you could have a Spider-Man Cameo
instead of just some misleading trailer
that makes you think there's going to be
heavy amounts of Spider-Man connectivity
to it yeah yeah so so another thing rpk
put out was that one draft for
Spider-Man 4 is already finished and the
plan right now is to shoot the movie
late 2024 now how I would do it
but I don't know if Sony would I would
introduce Yuri in that film because
obviously it's a new Tom Holland thing
he's kind of everyone's forgotten about
him he's out living his own life now
right complet he's no no longer in high
school he's off doing his own thing um
and I think working alongside the police
and so on that would be the way to
introduce Yuri but obviously you know
the whole thing with Sony is they have
their own disconnected Universe off
where Michael Keaton's at or whatever um
so I don't know if they would have to
get Marvel's permission well get
permission from Marvel Studios to
basically make a wraith movie connected
to the one with Tom Holland um but I
mean Tom Hardy kind of connected in a
way because he jumped across of that
univers and back just to drop off the
black suit but yeah interesting stuff
going on at Sony yeah oh man that that
literally Kevin fgy pulling pulling
Venom across to just get a little drop
of black suit it's like right you can go
now got it got it it's I remember once I
got invited into a YouTube um office for
a for a company that does a lot of
YouTube videos and they basically picked
my brains they promised me a job picked
my brains all day for what I would do
and then we're like oh yeah sorry we
don't want to work with you I was
thinking maybe that's exactly what
happened with Tom Hardy you know Kevin
[__] was just like yeah come on about
the come with the MCU got a portal set
up so you can jump through and then uh
yeah you can go home mate get yourself
out of here it's so good that that whole
movie no way home was so impactful and
so so memorable for a vast variety of
reasons because it makes you kind of
forget just how freaking pointless all
that was with yeah because that post
credit scene and let there be cage was
all the talk about that movie was Oh my
god like people were flipping out about
it and then it amounted to like nothing
and no way home yeah and and we it did
was not that much of a discourse because
it had a good it had a great movie to
overshadow that you know what I mean um
yeah they didn't even explain though how
he knew Spider-Man was Peter Parker
because in his Universe there's no
Spider-Man or Peter Parker I know they
had some line with Venom where he was
like I will show you the entire
Multiverse knowledge that I have because
we're connected as a hive mind but that
not that's not really f out that
Spider-Man's Peter Parker mate I think
that's think Kevin I think you were
pulling people's legs there but speaking
of Kevin pulling people in with his legs
leg low key sounds like leg key and lowy
season 2 episode 4 we got a chance to
see it Greg what did you think this is
the last last episode of Early Access
we're going to get yeah I I was exactly
the same when when we uh did the first
episode I was raving about it and then I
think you can see in in our tone like
while we really we've really been loving
Loki for the most part we've had our
like criticisms about two and three and
maybe not being as high of like a in in
terms of a a praise this was I I
messaged you after I watched it like
this is really it is it is one of my
favorite without spoiling anything I I
the thing that I took the most away away
from it in terms of an emotional
context is I genuinely thought it was
suspenseful and I don't actually say
that with any of the Disney plus Marvel
stuff even the ones I've Loved I I'm I'm
like you you can find something exciting
you could find something captivating but
the word suspenseful is very specific to
me like this is this is intense I don't
know what's going to happen and I'm
actually like on the edge of my like I'm
I'm like this is this is really
intense I loved this episode I think
it's really really great and I I hope
people love it as much as we do or else
something's wrong with me because I I
really I really think this is one of the
best Disney plus episode I I don't want
feel like I'm way overselling it now
where the expectations G to be so high
for it but I really do think it's one of
the best Disney plus episodes they've
ever
done yeah no I completely agree um I had
some problems with Jonathan Major's
acting in episode three I was a bit like
what's he doing he's like a bumbling
idiot take me back to the days where we
had threatening villains that I was
scared of he kind of tones it down for
this episode gives a much more personal
performance but there's still you know
the the comedic side to him and it's
ending what you're going to know when
you see it wow what an ending my jaw was
on the floor just did not see it coming
at all completely unexpected and the way
they go with it's kind of like crap
where do things go now it's it's really
well put together and structured um and
it kind of It kind of plays on some
things earlier in the season that you
we've seen getting pieced together but
it's almost it does it all in a way to
kind of trick you into a false sense of
security and it's so well done
everyone's just there's real dynamism to
the episode where it's constantly
jumping back and forth between certain
sides in one location
um and it just works really really well
I think I think this was up there for
for my you know it's between the first
episode in this one for my favorite in
the season so far but it was absolutely
brilliant and I can totally see why they
released these four to critics early and
yeah loved it loved it and and it's got
me excited to see to to venture into the
unknown where I don't know what's going
to happen and I'm not going to have that
advanced knowledge over everyone else
and we're all kind of going to
experience it together because I know
who moan about being YouTubers but it
can be tough being a Critic when you you
you kind of almost lose your excitement
sometimes because there'll be things
that we get sent like there was there's
a show that's not even out yet that I
got sent back at the start of September
and it's coming in the middle of
November and it's like I I I I was I
really enjoyed it um but I'm not allowed
to talk about it with anyone and it I
feel like by the point I get to it where
people are ready to talk about it kind
of be I don't want to brag but it'll be
like old news for me and my excitement
won't be maintained for that entire time
so when I see people talking about it
I'm just be like oh yeah yeah yeah it
was it was good wasn't it um so I'm
really excited with the way this ends
can't wait to see what happens next time
it's it's a very Central cast it's you
know it's it's your key figures from the
season so far that you you've all got on
board with you know Obby syby Hunter B15
the X5 you know they all kind of breing
them together and give them all really
interesting things to do and then I
think in the last 10 minutes they just
throw like three curve balls you way and
it's just like okay yeah excited to see
where this goes mean yeah the whole
thing just ramps up like I think the
last 10 minutes will be the talk of the
episode but I think the whole the entire
episode's great I think like the entire
thing is great and uh and the last 10
minutes will will be the talk of the
episode rightfully so like I didn't see
I didn't see any of that coming either
uh it's really maybe not even the last
10 minutes it's like the last 10 seconds
30 seconds yeah yeah it's it's pretty
awesome it's great stuff great stuff and
um I I what what's cool too
is like the last tidbit I would say
about it is
that season 1 ended in a way where the
talk of it was the last few minutes
right of of what happened in there and
then we had to wait a long time to see
if how any of this would affect anything
in in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
future movies you know like we had to
just kind of wait
and here we just have to wait one week
to see what happens and I'm like oh this
is really exciting you know that's
that's what I find really fun about it
no really good I I feel like it could
have been a season finale in all honesty
I feel like if ended it there you'd be
like oh crap and but yeah we've got two
more weeks after this it it's kind of
giv me the feeling that Loki season one
episode forwarded at the end where
something happens at the end and you're
just kind of like okay where where are
we going to go with this now but then
they spoiled that a bit by giving us a
post credit scene showing the three Loki
in the void it's kind of like that sort
of thing and it's you imagine that post
credit scene wasn't there you're just
like wow what the hell's GNA happen next
it's kind of leaving you with a feeling
of Myster and and yeah I can't wait to
talk about it properly when everyone's
seen it um and I will still be excited
for that thank God and but my excitement
is being pulled down Greg by
disappointment of Deadpool 3 getting
delayed um so the film yeah it got
pushed back you know it was for for
months they were saying oh the strikes
won't affect it it's going to be ready
and everyone everyone behind the scenes
is like no way mate it's getting delayed
just come out and say it just delay yeah
and yeah that's come to pass um so it is
now delay played yet director sha Levy
recently cast out on them even being
finished in time to make the release
date the new release date of July 26
2024 as he told the rap I wish I knew
and this is obviously all contingent on
the strikes which we talked about before
hopefully you know they they sort it out
this week when we release this as they
are talking today when this video comes
out but yeah disappointing and I it does
make me kind of worry a bit about Marvel
and how their hype's going to be
maintained because
unfortunately I don't feel like the
Marvels is going to really bring people
back on board and I don't feel like Ekko
is what if the same thing with that um
and I don't I don't know how Captain
America 4 is going to do because you
know it's it's kind of coming off the
back of Falcon and the Winter Soldier
which I I enjoy it but I know there's
people out there that have they have
mixed feelings on it and I was feeling
like Deadpool was going to be the
Surefire hit that was going to get
everyone excited for for things and and
just to see it get pushed back a bit
it's like I don't know it kind of feels
like oh no are they are they like
releasing so many projects in a row that
people might not be hyped for and then
dropping that when maybe the hype's
already evaporated but I mean I say that
I'm going to be their day one yeah I
mean the the teaser they released of
just Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman
talking that was enough to get me on
board the film um so yeah it's
disappointing seeing stuff get delayed
but it was expected yeah man what your
thoughts Greg my thoughts are Hugh
Jackman is probably getting laid so much
in the meantime now that he is okay do
don't think he's upset that he's broke
up with his wife I think divorce if if
it's necessary it's a good
thing okay it's something to be celebr
you shouldn't stay together if you're
not happy he's hug Jackman he's hug
Jackman he's gonna have a good time he's
gonna be enjoying enjoying life and been
married to her for like 30 years what
you about he's probably devastated well
no man I seeing he's he's huge Jackman
he's got the he's he's he's a senior
with a great body he's probably fine
he's probably I'm gonna have to cut all
this again no man no no I'm sure I'm
sure there's some hardship and I'm sure
one of his ways of
grieving is just taking advantage of a
single life man he's hug Jackman like
what what's this got to do with Deadpool
3 getting got to do with Deadpool 3 man
it's got everything to do we're so late
into the podcast we might as well talk
about it it's got everything to do with
Deadpool 3 you Jackman is wi is trying
to stay in shape he has to stay in that
Wolverine body till until they can get
back to filming he's gotta do something
with that body in the meantime right
come on Paul no one someone has to say
it someone has to say don't cut this
don't cut this is why people don't watch
the
podcasts this is why people don't watch
the podcast Craig H Jackman is getting
action right now to stay active until
Deadpool 3 reserves
filming um okay uh yeah I mean it's I
agree with you on a serious note I agree
with you I think I think Captain America
4 is
um I think it's a harder sell than
people are probably really realizing you
know and it's it's you're you're I don't
think you actually need to see Falcon
and Winter Soldier to watch it at least
I hope not I like Falcon and Winter
Soldier a lot the way the way Falcon and
the Winter Soldier finishes it's in the
exact same place as stuff was at the end
of end game yeah except now he's like
all right I got a suit and I'm more
confident about this decision now right
like that's about it um you have to sell
people boat they fix the boat fix the
godamn boat
dude I I think I think you I think you
need to to sell people on it but it
seems like it could be a really cool
political type of Thriller you know I'm
not talking like woke politic hul and
stuff yeah about Hulk and stuff I how
can that be a political thriller it can
be though dude I mean Hulk's got this
political SL about super soldiers and
[__] like that uh I I think you can I
think can do a really compelling trailer
out of it that can be very intense I'm
excited for the first look of it to see
what they do because I'm I'm rooting for
it I I am I am rooting for it because
even on my end you know like to go
from Steve Rogers to someone who's not
Steve Rogers I'm I'm of course going to
see it I'm of course interested and I
really like Anthony Mackey in the role I
I thought he was great in Falcon Winter
Soldier um at the same time it's it is
it is a harder it is a harder cell so I
I really want to I'm really hoping it's
going to do it but I I am on the same
page as you as I think Deadpool 3 would
have been the thing to reignite that
spark for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and I'm not sure this new Captain
America movie is is the way to go about
it because people still like a big part
of the conversation is and the reason
why I'm saying it's a battle is because
as much as there was the Falcon and
Winter Soldier show as much as you know
they had that big scene where he handed
off the shield we had Old Man Steve
Rogers and everything they're still
asking Chris Evans every freaking
interview will you come back and then he
still talks about whether or not he'll
come back and he's like you know I'm G
Talk completely off the table I might I
might I might still come back so there's
still that that little a little sther of
hope that he might return still you know
and and it it kind it does wash away the
enthusiast to see Anthony Mackey carry
on the mantle when so much of the
conversation is still about will will
Chris Evans return you know and and this
movie has a lot to prove that we sh this
has to be the defining moment where we
let Chris Evans go this is the this is
really it this film so A lot's writing
on it and that's why I'm Roo for it to
do well well I was texting Ryan Ary and
I was having the same conversation with
him and he said I think Captain America
4 and the Thunderbolts will do well and
I was like well the Thunderbolts is like
the sidekicks movie and they're still
kind of messing about with the script
and that yeah cap four you know I think
you're completely right I think it
depends how they integrate the Hulk what
goes down with that like the Hulk is my
favorite Marvel character and I always
feel like he's kind of been mishandled a
bit at the MCU kind I really like the
the early iterations yeah I mean the The
Avengers was great I thought Age of
Ultron was great and then they turned
him way too goofy like he he is the
perfect example of how Marvel have kind
of taken their big strong characters
turned them into goof who were complete
badasses they've turned them into goofy
like stupid comedic relief and I feel
that's the case with thorw um you know
that there's not that level of
seriousness with them and I'm hoping
that Captain America 4 had
it's Brave New World isn't it I keep I'm
deliberately saying Captain America 4
because I totally forgot what title it
is because they changed it it was New
World Order and they changed it Brave
New World um so yeah it's obviously
Harrison Ford's going to be playing the
general Ross which um well president
Ross sorry which they're going to be
getting in um Red Hulk with that as well
because remember in secret invasion they
said sounds like a one- turn president
to me which great great way to set
things up guys um but yeah I'm hoping
that they send Hulk back to the kind of
Rage monster where he's trying to
Grapple with you know the the the MCU
book talks it has a great chapter about
the Hulk and what they do in the book is
they kind of go through each film and
talk about the behind the scenes stuff
the character motivations to themes and
they're saying the the appeal of Hulk
which I've never realized is that he
everyone has the this urge within them
to just go get angry and just smash
stuff up and go over the top of it and
just go crazy which is what the Hulk
represents however Banner represents the
more cool mind after that the the side
of regret like you know when you lose
your cool and you kind of you let it all
out you go crazy and it feels good but
then you have that come down and that
regret of like oh no what have I done
Clarity of what you done exactly and
that is what the Hulk is and that is why
everyone can kind of relate to him
because we all have these two sides
within us and you know Banner is in
control most of the time but they'll be
certain point in your life when you you
lose your temper and just let it out and
you feel like oh crap I regret it none
of that's in the Hulk at the moment
smart Hulk was great for endgame I
thought he worked really well as part of
what the they were going for with that
but yeah how they used him in She-Hulk
and stuff just just wasn't well Ser to
the character that was once the one of
the main members of The Avengers and
since I've been nerfing him turning him
turning him into a joke you know ucing
his son in what is the worst
introduction ever just makes me less
excited to see what they're going to do
with him in the future so I'm hoping
that the Red Hulk brings the red back
out of him and they set it up as that
and I I I feel like the Captain America
could be very much in the same way that
Civil War was kind of an ensemble piece
and that they bring the Hulk in sort it
out and and that'll be good I think
that'll really Elevate the movie but for
the moment it feels like a lot of people
kind of see it as being all almost a
continuation of Falcon and the Winter
Soldier like it's difficult to go from
seeing something on TV on a streaming
service and then try and sell a movie
off the back of that it tends to be the
way around where it kind of feels like
we should have this expectation for
Sam's Captain America that he should be
a small screen character whereas I want
to really see them sell it as him being
the big guy um and I think that'll
obviously carry the movie but you know I
do feel the MCU hype if if they don't
deliver with that then it's going to
really suffer and it is kind of going
almost downhill a bit and we have kind
of seen that in the case of the Marvel's
box office um which is yeah the the
latest figures they have been updated so
tracking is forecasting 75 to 80 million
for an opening weekend so there's a
slight Improvement on what was before
but yeah I just still I mean it's less
than a month away and I just still don't
see the hype really getting on board for
it obviously the active you know they
can't promote the movie at the moment
but there's still not that that buzz to
it I think going back through this book
and hearing all this the the old movies
and going through the timeline and stuff
it like reminded me of what made me feel
like Marvel had magic you know what I
mean and I feel like that magic with
Marvel's kind of gone Loki really good
but I don't feel like there's that magic
around the the announcements in the
Slate at the moment you know every
release doesn't feel like oh crap we're
building up to the next thing and so it
just kind of feels like it's releasing
content for the sake of releasing
content so they can release content down
the line I just found the review embargo
for Marvels and it is it comes out
November 9 Thursday November 9th at
night right uh the review embargo is
November 8th in the morning which is
very late for a Marvel movie very very
late for a Marvel movie very
late I got my invite do they say what
social media reactions are uh Tuesday
November 7th at 9:00 p.m. Pacific
Standard time so the day before the
reviews lift that's a social media 12
hours before the reviews left yeah I
mean that is late and we deal a lot with
this like I was talking about
Loki like I'm sure that was the week
before or something most movies tend to
be most Marvel movies the social media
tends to be it's normally the
immediately after the premiere and
people go out and tweet their initial
thoughts and then I think it's normally
the Monday when the review embargo lifts
and then it releases on the Friday
whereas that I mean that's not that
doesn't fill me with confidence and
obviously he SC is this is so weird okay
so at least the first rounds of
screenings that they're sending out here
Tuesday it was just I'm I'm on the list
that most people are going to be on um
maybe they'll have earlier ones uh
Tuesday November 7th at 7 o'clock P.M
mov is an hour 45 minutes social media
embargo lifts 9 o'clock P.M so I think
the idea is like the second they're out
of the theater they should be tweeting
about it uh so yeah that's kind of late
that's that's really late uh I know
you're not confident Craig and people
might think we're being negative because
you know but just the way these things
tend to
operate we are we are negative to be
fair
but I I want to be positive genuinely I
do want to be positive but that doesn't
fill me with a lot of confidence and I
kind of feel like n Costa is almost
trying to get in front of it like if you
if you've been watching all reading what
her interviews are she's kind of been
saying like well Kevin's the one who's
in control of everything and sometimes I
was just direct to like a green ball or
a green screen or something and it it
kind of sounds like she's almost trying
to get in front of it and if it's bad
she can be like well was telling you
guys um but obviously you know that
they've they're trying to cash in on the
success of barie I feel um but whether
that's going to happen or not we'll have
to see I think what they've I think box
office analysts in general who who
mistaken things in the past and saying
like oh it's going to do Barbie numbers
and stuff I think they haven't realized
like Barbie is the most popular girls
toy in the entire world it's got a
massive history whereas Captain Marvel
it isn't you know and and again I think
it kind of comes down to audiences I
know women women went out and droves to
see Barbie like Marvel's main audience
is men and and women don't necessarily
associate Marvel is being something made
for them like how they think Bobby is um
and Disney kind of they built their
whole empire on on princesses and stuff
and I I feel I might be wrong with this
but what I feel they're trying to do is
almost take these male and this is
actually covered in the book as well but
they're taking these male Centric
franchises and putting women into to
attract both audiences into it um but
sometimes you
know it feels like that they're kind of
moving away from the the key demographic
that they really should and I don't feel
like they've fully marketed this movie
towards men um who are still they they
still make up the the basis of M I'm
trying to say it without sounding sexist
Greg and I don't know if I'm doing a
really good job with it but you know
what I'm trying to say you know I trying
to make the point clear out because we
we could always hear the other side
where people misunderstand what we're
saying and we're like no yeah we're just
talking about the context of the
characters and stuff we're not talking
about this you know at school it it was
the Nerds all the boy nerds were in a
Marvel you know what I mean I didn't see
the the girls sitting on the table
talking about Marvel and Captain Marvel
and stuff maybe things have changed
recently I've been in a school for a
long time um but it kind of feels like
they hav Haven necessarily marketed this
towards men now one thing they did with
Wonder Woman which I thought always
thought was very very smart to get men
to come in was that they had Steve
Trevor Chris Pine playing him and they
could at least be like well look it's
got something for the GU something for
the girls whereas this kind of feels
like they've sort of pushed it towards
just a a Barbie audience but again
you're like I'm not necessarily sure
that women grew up with Captain Marvel
in the same way that they did with bar
for example my wife rarely goes to
cinema but first night she was there for
Barbie talking about the models with her
she's like I'm not even interested in
seeing it and yeah I kind of feel like
women in general might not be up to
speed with the MCU in the same way that
men are and they're kind of maybe just
not as interested but I'm trying to
sound say this without sounding sexist
Greg you know what I'm saying I think
you pulled it off man uh I hope so don't
get divorced my male mind is saying you
don't sound sexist
I will I mean they got they got Nick
Fury in the
trailers
men men yeah but people watch secret
invasion you know I don't thinking about
it I I think because I've never really
and I'm not not saying this to toot my
own horn I've never really noticed like
the the whole thing when it's like a
woman lead or something until other
people are pointing it out and and it's
because I think it's because when I was
growing up I watched a lot of Hong Kong
Cinema and like like the specific like
the Jackie Chan and Jet Le the early
days of like with their actual Hong Kong
films and that's when I was really into
Michelle yo uh was her films and then I
had movies when I was like nine years
old like that had like Trinity and I
watched like my favorite film was
Terminator 2 and I loved aliens and you
know like I watched so many things with
female leads and and then there's like
there's also like Maggie Chun in Hong
Kong and stuff and and uh so to me I I I
guess I don't really notice it but then
it becomes such a a conversation that
I'm I'm a little unaware of like I love
like Kill Bill remember Kill Bill like
Kill Bill was was a huge film and it was
so much female Centric uh in front of
the camera and and um now though when
it's like a woman it be it's such a it's
such a conversation isn't it like it
it's it's really really strange cuz I I
don't really I don't really notice it
until someone points it out I mean you
put I'm exactly the same to be honest I
never really focus on it that much um
but what will often happen is I'll not
be thinking about it and then I'll go on
YouTube there'll be like 50 videos
already made about it and I be oh yeah I
guess so exactly maybe I should yeah
maybe I should boycott everything just
only watch movies from the 70s oh wait
they've got women in them too oh no what
godamn um so yeah very strange it's kind
of sad seeing this because I know they
were banking on it but just all the
things that we've we've seen there I
mean Marvel they need some consecutive
wins back to back they really do
guardians lowy great H and if they take
a dip here I feel like it's going to
almost set the mood back to how it was
kind of at the start of the Year where
people are like a bit down on Quantum
Mania you know Down On th love and
Thunder and kind of wanting Marvel to
really hit its stride again and I feel
like if this is a stumble then it might
kind of take them out of that which is a
shame uh but yeah this I mean we'll see
how it goes but that embargo date has
not filled me with confidence and uh
yeah I think the fact that the Stars
can't come out and promote it it's gonna
be it's going to be difficult what they
put in big bold red letters here is we
respectfully ask that you refrain from
revealing spoilers cameos character
developments and detailed story points
in order to give your audiences around
the world opportunity to enjoy our
movies to the fullest and allow them to
discover any surprises and plot twists
so maybe just maybe they're running it
late because there's going to be some
Game Changer stuff in here huh do you
believe do that with end game no at all
I don't believe this though they had
screenings way earlier for end game
even no way home they managed to keep
like Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield
secret and they still lifted the Embargo
like days and days before and people
like there's some big surprises in this
and you guys know what they are but you
definitely don't want to spoil it h so I
don't know if it's necessarily that but
we're gonna see Greg we're gonna see I
want the MCU do well and you know the
reason why I want the MCU to do well is
because I've been listening to the audio
book but see the reign of Marvel Studios
an Incredible Book Greg um I just wanted
to end the podcast talking about this
and I really really do I think um if you
guys are interested in listening to very
relaxing voices talking about the
history of Marvel then you need to go
pick up that audio book or if you like
the text and you like to feel a book in
your hand and read it or even if you
like it on your Kindle you guys need to
go check it out the the this has became
my almost my go-to now of kind of
looking at what went into the movies and
all the creative efforts behind them
there was so much in this that I learned
about the studio and all the ups and
downs with it the way it starts is it
begins on really quick can I can I ask a
quick question quick question before
before um is that the so much of what
comes out about this is is a lot of like
almost like dramatic reveals of things
that that people talk about it but is
the is it made from like like Disney
produc this or did some like journalist
do like who the one who created this
book is my question so it was Joanne
Robinson and her team I'm not sure who
they are unfortunately um but she's kind
of been the person who's been going on
the podcast talking about it so Disney
were originally on board with her doing
it and they were completely open and
then it got to a point where they were
kind of like don't speak to her please
don't say anything and I don't know if
it's because I I I kind of feel like
they might have been expecting a puff
piece right what she did was uncover you
know the the good stuff and the bad
stuff and this feels like a real
documentation of what actually went on
during the time and it actually it
starts off on the Avengers like The
Avengers is premiered I think and it's
Kevin fige basically sitting with the
core cast and then he starts saying like
we're gonna be making Cinematic Universe
and then it kind of spirals out from
there it goes back to the 70s it talks
about the early days of Marvel the bankr
ruptcy um Acquisitions Tois getting
involved Ron Pearlman and then it kind
of goes through the start of it with
Iron Man all the casting process behind
him and then pretty much every chapter
from that point on is it's taking a film
talking about how it was made the
difficulties with it what went well and
there's just so much stuff in it that I
just even things that I thought I knew
it expands on them so much um for
example Jos Weeden I actually didn't
realize how much of a hand he had in the
decisions of the way that the MCU was
going to go um and all his drama with
Agents of Shield and stuff also Robert
Downey Jr as well didn't realize how
much of a hand he had in crafting stuff
and then it goes into things like the
Sony acquisition there's also a civil
war within Marvel itself where it's
talking about how Marvel East Coast were
kind of at war with Marvel West Coast
because they were deciding what they
couldn't couldn't do and it's just so
well structured it really makes it's a
trip down memory lane basically and I
think if you listen to it or if you read
it you're going to remember why you fell
in love with this stuff in the first
place and it as soon as I've I've
finished it I was like I really want to
go back and watch the MCU from the start
again which is a feeling I haven't felt
for so long because there's been such a
focus on the future and and new content
in these new shows and stuff and I've
not really had time to go back and
appreciate those older movies like
during the pandemic
I think I watched through the MCU in
total twice um obviously there was a lot
less titles back then but it there
wasn't any new content coming out and I
just went back and I just would watch
through them like maybe one a day and it
was I really did enjoy that time and
gotten away from it but this made me
remember why why I loved it and it's
just it's got great interviews with
people on board every everything you
would want to know and it's structured
in a way where it's it's like a story
almost it it has like the the highs and
lows and and what goes into it and the
the you appreciate the genius behind the
MCU and and yeah I just absolutely loved
it I think it's definitely worth
checking out um and I'm no I've no doubt
I'm going to be referencing it in future
work and and talking about it so much so
yeah if you guys are looking for an
audio book or something to read or you
know just even just to you want to learn
one thing about a certain film say say
Civil War is your favorite and you want
to learn something like for example
Marvel East Coast didn't think that Tony
star should be in the film and they also
didn't think that Heroes should fight
each other and they so they didn't want
the Tony stalk in it at all they didn't
want the airport battle scene and just
crazy stuff like that and the fights
that they had to do to really get those
things included in the film it it's so
it's worth picking up and yeah must have
for for people who are interested in
Marvel if you if you listen to this
podcast I'm guess and you are and you
know if you like a balanced view on
things it's not just like the one that
Disney released where it's like Marvel
was the greatest thing ever and it had
no difficulties and everyone really
enjoyed working there and there was no
strain at all it even goes into things
like why Edward Norton and Kevin fary
didn't get along and what he was
promised and then how he kind of took
over the project and stuff and yeah it's
so well detailed and I think I think
you're going to love it if if you check
it out which you should you should and
go and support the book because it's
really really good Why can't your brand
deals ever be this good Paul you just
they should be man I should really hit
them up and be like when am I getting
paid for this I'm Shilling now totally
sold me on this man I'm just like damn
if you could do this for your those
cereals what is the magic
spoon yeah if I'd be buying so much
magic spoon right now like damn just got
really sold me all this magic spoon
should go check it out that that was
great that no I mean I didn't I I had
the Imp I asked you that question
because I had that impression that it
was like a Marvel puff pie thing that
they're producing being like here's why
Marvel's great that's what I thought and
then I'm hearing these stories I was
like oh apparently not so now you just
open my eyes to it yeah you genuinely
got me intrigued yeah about it yeah and
I mean even on Audible if you haven't
had a free trial on that you can go
listen to there but fantastic work man
damn dude you saw me on a like you're
brand if you did this for manscaped I'd
be buying some more I'd be shaving my
balls more often I do do this for
mancate um but yeah fantastic you know
what it makes me optimistic that the MCU
can be saved again I know we're very
negative but I feel like documenting
stuff like this like I'm sure Kevin fy's
listened to it or read it I'm sure the
guys picked it up and went through it
and I I feel like this might even spark
in him it be like yeah you know what
we've messed up let's let's go back and
fix stuff let's fire the Daredevil rers
yeah let's waste $150 million on
Daredevil and go back to square one you
son of a [__] we're back this book made
me fire everyone from dir oh man yeah so
yeah I wish I could just sit and talk
about it all day but I feel like if I
start spoiling stuff then people might
not go read it
the dud done a fantastic job with it
loved it um one of one of the if you're
yeah if you're a fan of Marvel please go
read it and please hit the thumbs up
button on this video And subscribe and
also go listen to us on Spotify Amazon
and anyway get your podcast gang Apple
podcast so yeah that's another episode
crazy crazy stuff going on in the world
right now um so I hope you've enjoyed
this little hour and a half break away
from it all and uh thank you again guys
for for stopping by and checking us out